à à
ờ ờ
Hôm nay thật là thì tùy có vẻ là Nghe có
vẻ là
Anh nhìn
nhầm
crd2 bảng thì nó sẽ giữa phức tạp nhưng
mà tí tối cốt thì mình sẽ thời gian
nhanh bởi vì làm xong một hàng thì copy
xong rồi copy paste sang hàng còn lại sẽ
rất là nhanh nên là bây giờ tôi nghĩa
vẫn có kịp thời gian để mà tâm sự một tí
Cho tôi xin phép bà
em tâm sự một tí đã được ạ
Và bây giờ cũng đang có mỗi vài ông ấy
thì
ở đầu tiên thì hôm trước tôi còn nói
chuyện về
gửi đứa bạn thì bạn đang bảo là nó đang
mông như cho đùa kiểu hiện tại của nó
hoặc kiểu dạng mà nó đang không có gì
trong tay ta và đang đi làm thêm để đỡ
lao động chân tay từ bồi bàn cứ thứ cũng
không theo đúng ngành này nó nó là ngành
công nghệ thông tin chúng tôi nhưng mà
nó học đại học mà xong rồi nó không
không không làm được đấy nó không theo
được đấy bởi vì không phải không theo
được ở trên giường mà chỉ đơn giản là
Họp xong học xong đi làm học trên trường
nó bị lý thuyết quá cơ bản quá đi hoàn
trả dụng được gì cả Thì giờ nó vẫn kéo
không làm theo đúng này nào chưa tìm
được việc vân vân thì
Vì thế nên là ông đấy cũng cũng gọi là
nhà cũng đánh giá mình kiểu hơi tự tin
một tí Thế ông ấy không dám tán gái kiểu
thế không làm bạn gái rồi bạn nghĩ rằng
cầu mình đang Chả có gì trong tay mình
đang phân vân không tự tin mà tệ nào khá
tự ti thì
Ừ thôi có nói không Đấy Đó là cái gì
nhất là ông người có tôi cảm thấy ông
người còn năng lực chẳng qua ông ấy có
thể đạt đã chuẩn bị đi sang hướng chứ
không có nghĩa là ông đấy không tương
lai mày sẽ kiểu mịt mù hay gì cả mà ông
phải tự tin mà bạn thân lên bởi vì tôi
đã từng như thế và tôi nghĩ ai từng như
thế nó kiểu cảm thấy tương lai mông lung
cho cậu
mất niềm tin cảm thấy chẳng có tin nào
mà cái gì cả
Ừ nhưng mà tôi khác mấy bạn đấy à Nó về
đúng nghĩa là tôi không có một cái gì cả
thật từ bạn bè không có gia đình
cũng chán nản sau đó thì chưa đọc hàng
như cũng kiểu
cũng kêu bình thường đấy
Ừ lúc đấy tôi chỉ có thư duy nhất là cái
niềm tin thôi không có niềm tin được xa
tôi cảm thấy tôi đã từng nghĩ à Ai chẳng
từng nghĩ việc à từ xa mà từ từ các thứ
thứ
Ừ nhưng mà tôi không
không không chọn con được đấy rất là nội
mới chỉ có niềm tin là tao cứ nghĩ là
mọi thứ sẽ ổn thôi cứ cố làm cổ tin là
một cái điều gì đó Cái ngành này thì
thực sự đến năm đầu các bạn làm được
việc rồi các bạn vẫn mông lung Nhưng mà
trò đùa vậy các bạn cảm thấy à Chưa đi
làm được 2 vạn vật
Hà Nội dung cái niềm tin ở trong cuộc
sống tôi thấy một thứ rất quan trọng mà
cái tương lai một sự không ai thể cho
thắng được kể cả ông
Ừ ông xã đâu có là nhắn tin chia nữa
chưa chắc à đoán được tương lai thực sự
của ông
Ừ mình chính là mình làm chủ Tương Mai
không tin nội bộ toàn không tin bất kỳ
ai nói gì cả tự mình quyết định tương
lai mình số phận mình là do mình quyết
định đấy tôi có những quan điểm rất dứt
khoát vì những vấn đề đấy mà niềm tin nó
sẽ khiến cho tôi củng cố những cái hành
động thôi
từng đi vào toán đi cậu xem bói cho tứ
với nghỉ xong rồi xem tử vi xem quyển
sách cái gì đó tôi không bật tin là mấy
cái điều đấy
kiểu tự nhiên nó còn nói tốt với mình cả
tương lai mình giàu em ạ những nhưng mà
tôi không có tôi không tin được à bói
toán bói tương lai tới dầu với tôi sẽ
chỉ ngồi chơi thôi đợi đúng phát tôi
giàu à không nó ngon nữa tôi sẽ
để xem niềm tin mình làm thôi Ừ vội toàn
nói tốt với mình ở mình cũng cảm thấy nó
vui có thể nó sẽ thành sự thật
ô chữ bài toán về bảo là
năm sau anh sẽ kiểu mất chẳnghạn hai cái
gì đó gồm nhiều ý nghĩa của lời tiên tri
ấy đúng không Thì thì ông sẽ sống nha
ông sẽ sống tốt lên không sẽ sống tệ hơn
mà bạn cả đến đúng ngày khi ông không
bớt thì như thế nào ngon thì thôi ạ này
Tôi chẳng bao giờ ở trả vờ tin vào một
cái gì đâu tuyệt đối về Em về mấy cái mà
người khác đã nói về tương lai mình nghe
mà tự tương lai do mình quy định duyên
số hay mọi thứ do mình có những hết
mày mấy cái
các truyền thuyết về con người còn đánh
bại thần
Ừ cái đấy nhưng mà thôi Nó hơi là màn
quá đại khá là tôi có niềm tin mãnh liệt
vào mấy cái kiểu mình làm chủ số phận
mình cái kiểu thế
a tiếp theo có cái video này thì nhờ tôi
vừa mới lưu Đại Hiệp
Ừ ừ
được đâu biết tại sao tôi muốn
Xong rồi đây nữa không cho tôm vừa mua
chả sao hiện quảng cáo trên Facebook ảo
vãi đấy nhưng mà cái vấn đề không muốn
nói các bạn Chuyện gì có hai mặt bố
trong những cái mà hay của IOS mới đó là
nó chắc khiến cho ứng dụng Facebook
không theo dõi được đứng và phân phối
quảng cáo để cho chúng ta đây chúng ta
cứ nói là mỗi khi ta nói chuyện gì để
Facebook biết nó quảng cáo ngay hiểu như
là tôi đã nói về việc làm Tôi muốn học
chứng chỉ thêm về tiếng Pháp được ông
Dương tự nhiên Facebook tôi hiện quảng
cáo massage nuru Chả hiểu sao lại hôm
nay tôi đang bảo là con nó muốn học thêm
mà đánh golf shopee quảng cáo bán với
cái đầu nó không nữa tôi chả hiểu gì cả
nhưng bà đây cũng là thứ mà tôi nghĩ
rằng là bây giờ rất nhiều người sẽ gặp
và tương tự do với tôi thật đó là khi nó
ra chặn Facebook Lấy thông tin không
phải là nó ở phân phối quảng cáo đi
chúng ta mình nó đang quảng cáo Quá
nhiều thứ vẫn phải ta sẽ cùng nhau đi
xem người ta vòng có gì thế không
nhã tôi cho mấy hôm nay một đoạn thôi
Thì đại khái thì anh anh ấy hiểu qua
công nghệ cho tôi anh không Anh em biết
về công nghệ Nhưng mà không phải là dân
công nghệ thông tin như bọn mình thật sự
thì cái vừa rồi thì bây giờ thằng is và
hình như là có vài hôm nữa rồi 3 ngăn
chặn việc là các ứng dụng thu thập thông
tin của người dùng thì cái đấy à là ngọn
na ná giống như kiểu mày không tra
Google nó sẽ đề xuất ví dụ Giả sử về tôi
trả thời tiết Nga chặn lại
Bởi vì nó xác định là tôi đang ở Hà Nội
không chứ Ở đây đang ở chỗ khu vực này
này nó sẽ đề xuất tới giờ chuẩn Còn nếu
mà ông xã xử ông cha bằng bác bác gấu
này thì ạ Ừ thì thấy cái này nó sẽ là
kiểu riêng tư hơn ơi
thể chính xác
kiểu dạng là ông đang ở đâu Vân Vân Để
như vừa rồi các trang tiếng Việt đến nó
sẽ gợi ý Kiểu tiếng Việt có thứ cái cái
vừa rồi một phần là do thằng này nó còn
nhận diện mà nó thu cho nó giận nhận
diện location như hài sẽ thả nó phải
công nhận diện location Lego nó công cụ
tìm kiếm trở lại không thu thập thông
tin này dùng thì thì đấy nghĩ em bé uống
sẽ thấy là có những lúc mà thu thập
thông tin người dùng có lợi để bụng với
mục đích là để mà hỗ trợ cho mình mà
đúng ạ đứng yên là nó hơi bị sai thời
điểm mà nó thu thập rồi nó bán Thằng thứ
ba thở ra là không hẳn hay lắm Nhưng mà
nếu mà nó thu thập và nó để mà em hỗ trợ
cho mình thì còn hơn cái việc mà không
thu thập bởi vì à như anh Vinh anh vừa
nói đó là chắc chắn là nó vẫn sẽ quảng
cáo cho mấy ông thôi chả con nó sẽ để nó
sẽ quảng cáo những cái mà trong tầm tuổi
của ông hỏi cả trong khu vực Hạnh quanh
ông thì sẽ cái gì mà vân nên nó sẽ rất
là nhà nên mụn Nếu mấy ông muốn xem cầu
dạng mà đến tầm tuổi của mấy ông đã bị
ông còn khai ông Dân công nghệ thông tin
này nó sẽ đề xuất quảng cáo với bệnh
viện chị ạ
Đấy hạn chế bờ sầu này mất lần nữa thì
mới mấy ông có thích điều đấy không hay
thì thằng bạn đâu mà kiểu tự nhiên nhìn
thấy quảng cáo đấy trên Facebook nói anh
nghĩ ông bị bệnh nói thật
đấy nó còn tệ hơn ngoạn tha nó quảng cáo
gì đó nó Ừ đúng những thứ Ông tìm kiếm
trừ khi mấy ông Tìm kiếm Cũng bài thứ
tương tự thế rồi không nói ờ
không Hôm nay phải qua được
làm với 2 bảng đã rồi buổi sau mình sẽ
dạy các bạn sang bên OB sau mình mình
cắt buổi của mình sẽ gần như là sử dụng
cốt hôm trước thỉnh thoảng sẽ đập đi làm
lại thôi nhưng thường là sử dụng có hôm
trước và sửa lại để mà sao cho các bạn
thấy là nó sẽ thay thay đổi lần nghĩa
buổi hôm trước học ví dụ là học một cộng
một bằng hai bạn hôm nay sẽ thay dấu
cộng này thấp nhân ở ngọn thì sẽ ra kết
quả như thế nào Cái kiểu như thế đấy thì
ah không Ví dụ thì hơi sai ví dụ tôi Chị
chuẩn rồi à
vì một cộng một bằng hai thì bây giờ
biến thành 1 x2 = mấy nặng hơn chỉ Kết
quả nó phải Tân Nương nghĩa là cái phần
hiển thị được ăn nó tương đương thôi
nhưng cái cốt của mình cái tổ chức cốt
mình nó sẽ khác đấy
a
tiếp theo Thực ra tôi tâm sự nốt cái này
cho dù nó chả liên quan đến từ dân công
nghệ discard nhưng mà tôi
cho tôi bảo tôi tôi sẽ hướng đến 500m Mà
nè tôi Đôi khi tôi sẽ tâm sự với góc
nhìn của tôi một tí à
À mà thôi Tôi nghĩa chủ đề này đến cuối
buổi nói đi tôi sẽ nói về một cái mà thử
Tôi vừa xem
Ừ thứ nhất là mấy hộ mấy ông Hôm trước
có mà thường xuyên mấy ông hỏi thôi việc
cho tôi học tiếng Anh như thế nào kết
hợp việc làm học tiếng Anh thì cho tôi
từng nói đó là nếu không phải đắm chìm
vào tim anh hơi cạo rồi Nếu mà xem xem
phim nghe nhạc và Vân những hồi đấy là
tôi làm mấy cái đấy thì đúng là tôi nghe
nghe nhạc đã xem phim không cần phụ đề
nhưng mà về phát âm cũng như là
ở chung nhà về viết này phát âm này Đọc
mình thỏa còn tệ này bởi vì Xem phim mà
và tạm biệt là mấy ông không phải lôi
với mỗi đúng kiến thức đấy để mà đi thi
ở trường hay là thi Ielts được thì hồi
cấp 3 tôi Đặc biệt cô giáo tiếng Anh tôi
thể hiện rõ đậu vùi dập tôi luôn nó kiểu
dạng kiếm mày không được thêm của dao
đúng đúng nghĩa Tôi chẳng biết kể mấy
ông chưa đó là rồi nha cô Xin
mời bạn lên kiểm tra miệng à
ở bãi sao đời xa hai câu cô cho Tám Rồi
đi xuống tôi sao rồi Kiểu cuộc gọi tôi
lên rồi còn tự tin rồi mấy cái này dễ mà
Đấy xong rồi nó trả lời đúng hết sạch
bài thứ nhất và ơi sai khá rồi cậu Cô
bảo là mày thứ 2 vẫn làm đúng hết Xong
rồi cô vào làm thế mày thứ ba làm bài
thứ ba xong sai đúng một câu cô bạn ngồi
tưởng thế nào rồi cho bảy điểm đi xuống
đúng khi họ luôn 2 cả lớp cá ạ Có thể rõ
là có thể hiện rõ động giặt Hàng ngày
tôi không hiểu là bài thứ Ba ở tôi đúng
hết thì cô bác làm bài đến mày mà nhiều
bởi cái sai rồi đấy thì nói chưa cô các
bà tôi đúng thể hiện như thế luôn mà tôi
khẳng định ở tiếng Anh cô các bà ấy có
khi là kém hơn cả rồi vì vẫn nhớ cái hồi
mà vui có hành quyển sách quyển sách học
tiếng Anh cơ bản ở trên bàn Cô và cô đọc
cái đấy Thật chứ không phải mẹ con cô
được nhá
cục phát âm tiếng Anh bật cười em nhưng
mà tại Thái Cô ấy làm tôi chán tiếng Anh
từ thời cấp 3 và khiến tôi kiểu học
tiếng Anh tệ hơn thì hồi đời tôi có có
một chị gia sư Chị ấy cũng tốt phết mà
chị xinh nữa
để mà xinh vợ chị nhà có tuổi nó vẫn
thích à Thì
anh chị đấy là động lực to lớn của tôi
để học tiếng Anh
sức khỏe mới sinh em nhé bởi vì cậu chị
lấy cậu truyền được cảm hứng cho tôi
cũng như là
dạy rất hay nói chỗ nào về cơ bản ở
truyền được cảm hứng thôi chứ tôi khả
năng tự học tôi vẫn đùa tốt và
ở những chỗ mà chị đấy cũng là kiểu ở
truyền truyền hổ chương dạy ở lò đào tạo
IELTS luôn còn bây giờ Chị tự mở lớp
riêng tôi để Linh ở đây để Bởi vì tôi à
Ý tôi là trò một trận Trả chó đó thứ hai
của chị ấy và cũng bị lâu lắm rồi từ hồi
cấp 3 bây giờ chờ lâu lắm rồi nhỉ
Ông Ngoại trưởng hồi cấp 3 mình là 10 10
15 hả Bây giờ 16 bây giờ
25 tuổi mỗi lần 10 năm rồi đấy ạ
khi nghe tôi vẫn sẽ để lên ở đây quảng
cáo cho bé ông Thế mở lớp ở Hà Nội nhá
và Tí nữa chị thấy sinh bị và có tuổi
Nếu mà Cái quan trọng là lớp chị thằng
con gái xinh không ạ Tải vậy chứ Tìm đứa
đó toàn cái xinh
đi học còn động lực à
à à
anh dương vật này tô quảng cáo hơi lộ
liễu một tí
Ừ nhưng mà tôi quảng cáo trong bếp ông
thường mà những cái ấy mà tôi chính nhất
Sẵn đem lại cho tôi cái gì chỉ đơn giản
là tôi cảm thấy nó nó tốt thật thì thôi
quảng cáo cho bé uống thôi
ông lướt qua xem nhanh nhỉ
à hài chửi cho xem trên điện thoại
Ừ đợi tí nhé Vì vậy tôi xem cái này trên
à
Ừ biết rồi
nói chỗ nào hay video này thì Tóm tắt
lại vậy Hay video này đề xuất hai cái
mẹo khá 21 mẹ và một mẹo là Kiều thứ
ngày tháng ở trong Excel có để hiển thị
là Thành A không một ngày cụ thể trong
mới xem Nó kiểu như này
anh à Mấy thôi không ấy Seo tôm cái Xem
sheet.new này nó sửa cụ thể một ngày
tháng gì đó
thật sự không một này à
anh không
1978 ạ Như này sau đó thì nó sẽ bằng một
cái gì đó này ra cái thứ là sử dụng là
bằng cách này
ở nhà trọ ngắn
ở
sao rồi có cách ở trong mẹ này nữa nó sẽ
biến ảnh được từ tiếng Việt cơ thì thì
để mẹo Tôi thấy video để được mấy chục
nghìn lượt thích sau một nhẹ thứ hai nữa
là kiểu thay vì một có bảng vàng dọc như
này rồi các bạn ông Ấn xăm bằng xăm của
mình cái thằng trên thu hồi ở đoạn cuối
này vẫn ở xa mà em trên thì bạn ấy có
xinh phát kiểu an tp có nhớ để cậu nhiên
như thế nào đấy nhở đấy tôi thấy à kìa
khi tôi thấy à Mấy mẹo kiểu như thế rất
nhiều người ủng hộ hai sáng các thử thử
thấy giờ hai xong rồi còn theo dõi thêm
mấy kênh đấy để mà học được thêm nhiều
cái thấy cái nửa hai nửa tệ Tại sao phải
tệ cái này tôi nói thẳng luôn đó là bây
giờ có rất nhiều thầy đang dạy sao hai
người đang di chuyển đấy Sao có được mức
tại ở điểm và Mấy người đang làm cho mấy
người kia thụ động trong việc học
khi mua bia à anh Bởi vì có những cái mẹ
như thế thì mình nên hướng dẫn ra cách
tra gồm như tôi hướng dẫn mấy ông cách
tra Google để mở tìm kiếm một cái gì anh
anh nói thẳng là mấy cái mẹo này trao
gồm 1 phát ra ngay Thay vì phải lục lại
video mấy ông để xem cũng như phải cố
nhớ xem nói cái gì không vậy không Mình
không bao giờ cần phải nhớ cái phím tắt
mà cái gì cả hãy nhớ cái mẹo vặt nào như
thế này không
à Thế bây giờ Bây giờ mình không không
biết được cái mẹo đấy làm như nào rồi
kết hợp với việc là
nghỉ kia chưa đăng ấy video ở thôi Mình
chịu à
à à
Ừ cái đấy tôi thấy tốt ở điểm là có
truyền cảm hứng là do mấy ông thích về
Excel có thể làm được những gì nó rất là
tốt nhưng cái nhược điểm ở đây đó là
việc mấy ông bị thụ động quá về cố Hãy
xem tất cả những cái video đấy để mình
biết là hết mẹo thế rất là sai bổ vì
toàn bộ những cái mà mình có thể làm thì
tra Google là ra à
Ừ
ông kia đang hỏi là phải biết có nó mà
tra thì nếu không có cha thì xem coi
không được mà ứng dụng nhưng mà nên
trang bằng tiếng Anh hỏi ra tiếng Việt
ví dụ giả sử như em trường hợp này nhá
đầu tiên thì biến biến biến này Thành
đây thì đấy sẽ là thường sẽ biến thì sẽ
Converse này
để biết
tootec đấy nó đề xuất luôn này tách hoa
cà which they were named này
nó xảy ra này đúng không mà Mấy ông muốn
sang vừa nãy ông kêu còn bảo là có thể
biến sang tiếng Việt thì mình có sẽ là
language như này
pha ra luôn
Ừ Để xong mẹ không có về à
cho tôi sẽ dạy mấy ông cách tra Google
chứ không phải là
nhớ cắt từ khóa để mà bấm xong rồi phải
nhớ cả cụ mày bấm không không cậu sẽ chỉ
hướng dẫn mình cái tra thôi ví dụ điển
hình giống như bạn vừa nãy bảo cách để
mà để mà xăm đây xăm thấy bố mày treo
bạn như này
Đấy sau đó thì lấy kéo xuống này nó có
cái phím tắt nó sẽ có cái phím tắt là
cắm t là sẽ ăn luôn cả bảng này xong Tại
sao chúng ta phải cũng ở những cái từ
khóa và cố đậu những cái video người ta
dậy
Ừ
đúng rồi
Chị chuẩn là sẽ dạy mấy ông người cắt
key word thì mày không chào Google chứ
không phải là dạy cho mấy ông mấy kiến
mẹo như thế này thì đúng là mấy mẹ mày
rất là hai mấy ông có thể không biết ok
nhưng mà có nhiều nhưng mà ý tôi ý Nó là
kiểu mấy ông sẽ bị Nếu mà nhiều bạn đấy
nó sẽ bị thụ động thụ động việc học chủ
động việc đội có video mới ra để biết
được thêm cái Mẹo gì đó mà cố phải tìm
lại thì đi nào đấy để biết được cách làm
chứ không biết trao gồ mấy ông sẽ cố tìm
lại video này thì mà làm các bạn với mấy
ông chẳng biết được lấy đâu
à à
cho nên là
A và đấy mình mang tiếng mình dân công
nghệ nhưng mình biết cách trao gỗ để
mạnh làm được mấy cái tin học như thế
này mình nghĩ mình sao Mình kế toán được
chủ động tìm kiếm và mình nên chủ động
cậu nói chung là nếu thấy mình sẽ biết
được có rất nhiều thứ làm được nữa chứ
không phải mỗi mấy mẹ nữa đúng không ạ
mấy ông có thể hỏi người khác key Word
để tránh cái học lập trình nhỏ như thế
sẽ không có tỷ Hà mà Mấy ông không phải
biết nó phải tra trước mình không phải
đội một ai đó hướng dẫn kiểu Đề xuất cho
một cái hàm gì đó
à à
Ừ nếu hiểu gì tôi không ạ
bạn kia đang nói là
ở
Clickbuy hơi kỳ đáng lẽ phải trẻ tăng
Trần và mấy hết đúng không phân sinamay
hết chỉ là cái mà mình sẽ dạy vào Open
này mình sẽ dạy các bạn về cái đấy thôi
ok con buổi hôm nay bạn chắc là vẫn sẽ
in groups
Ừ đúng rồi mày cái video đấy giáo dục
thì mấy đâu nó nó có cái tốt ở điểm là
nó làm cho mình cảm thấy kích thích về
việc ở Excel của Excel cảm thấy hấp dẫn
này có đam mê thêm ấy sao thì được
nhưng mà đấy thì được cái ở bên có nhớ
được đâu Mấy ông có nhớ được là người ta
làm đã làm những cái gì ra cái điều đấy
đâu ông ạ sợ mấy ông chạy video không
không như thế Ok nhờ Thôi bây giờ xong
rồi buổi hôm nay bắt đầu nhá á
ờ ờ
cho tôi một tí ý
ừ ừ
cô
Linh
Linh thôi nghỉ à
à à
bạn lớp trưởng tạo cho anh cái link mít
tiếp nhé rồi tôi sẽ chia sẻ cho mày
không phải Linh ở đây
ở mỗi buổi lại phải gửi Linh cũng hơi
mệt à
ông cúi không ở nhà mất tích đâu đấy ạ
người anh không dậy Cái đấy được
có thể vào xem à paste ôm cùng với tôi
đúng không và một Linh thì mấy ông có
thể vào link bạn kia để bạn ấy tự chia
sẻ cho biết không với hôm nay mình sẽ
dạy cho các bạn sẽ theo như thế này ví
dụ hôm trước mình sẽ vào thì nó sẽ là
cậu em lên cao nhé
như thế này không ạ nhưng thực ra là
thực ra là mình Bây giờ mình sẽ muốn làm
theo cổ là hiển thị ra à
cho các sinh viên và cả lớp bây giờ mình
sẽ có thêm cả lớp nữa
A và mình nhập vào nhập vào à
lớp theo kiểu có mã lớp thôi là được rồi
Anh chưa chơi cần làm phức tạp hội tôi
tôi sẽ nâng cao tuần sau
cho mấy ông
em đổi tỉ lệ V chị sẽ có là gì
you school Witch
I
read the table lớp này
mã in a
tôi tạm bỏ qua mấy cái giường đà sau 72
giờ vẫn đúng rồi ô tô phiên mình vẫn
đăng ký thật
tôi tạm bỏ qua khóa ngoại tao thử nhé
chị sau nhé ê
nữa đi 1 cột 1 cột mà lớp đi à
à
làm việc tí nó Đôi khi mình sẽ làm việc
của đêm thôi à
ở bên mình sẽ có bảng lớp ở sinh viên và
bây giờ mình sẽ chấp nhận Cốt lại hết
toàn bộ cốt hôm trước đi nếu mà sẽ theo
một tí format khác tí cho bé ông xem qua
nhé
Ừ ok đầu tiên thì như tôi bảo là luôn có
tạo phải đánh trước này
vội Tôi muốn khi mới vào trang web như
thế này
khi mới vào trang web như thế này có cần
muốn hiển thị ra có cái Menu ở đây là
hiển thị ra là một cái Menu xong rồi có
thể bấm vào danh sách sinh viên này sang
sách lớp gì đó thì sẽ ổn hơn thì tôi sẽ
cần gọi đến một thằng tôi như tôi từng
nói anh sẽ gọi đến mua hàng là thằng
controller đã thằng con Zalo nó sẽ làm
gì Làm sao bằng bộ bàn đúng ạ sẽ làm gì
Làm sao mình sẽ lickytung controller
được ạ
anh em cho anh chàng Ngọc Ánh Ừ đợi thì
con trả lời này nó sẽ làm gì đó Đầu tiên
thì bây giờ tôi muốn à nó cầm là chèn
thêm cái máy ngủ em ạ Nhưng giờ như tôi
đã nói thì mình nên luôn để cái file
view nằm trong thư mục view Tí nó sẽ có
rất nhiều view đấy thì mình lên đó cho ở
trong môi thư mục riêng
thì mình sẽ review này
anh xóa tạo file đây là menu chấm pp này
ở đây mình sẽ có thể 216 to là
ở đây là menu chẳng hạn
ở đó sau đó thì mình sẽ có thường mình
sẽ có oli kiểu ngay
a cho thể a a thôi danh sách
lớp cho này kiểu ngay mục alo đi
và đây sẽ là danh sách sinh viên này ạ
theo chuẩn như thế
Bây giờ khi mình bấm Mình muốn bấm vào
cái danh sách lớp này bản chất là nó sẽ
nhảy đến một cái gì đó không ạ Mình sẽ
mình cần mình bấm nhảy đến sẽ chưa lên
hai địa chỉ này một cái gì đó để mình
hiểu được là nhảy sang bên lớp chứ mày
nghỉ chẳng đến sinh viên là sử mình sẽ
có hai thằng nọ một thằng lớp rồi thằng
sinh viên không ạ
thì mình cần phân biệt ở bấm là thằng
này nó sẽ nhảy ở bên lớp bấm thằng ảnh
để bên sinh viên không ạ
Ừ thì thì mình cần ở đây tôi sẽ truyền
lên đây nó sẽ khác rồi Đã trận hôm trước
mình làm tôi có thể có thể truyền lên
đây Container là ạ bằng ở đây một thằng
là lớp một thằng đấy sẽ sinh viên là đã
cầm nhà
mình hãy bấm vào đây sẽ chuyển một
Angeles và bấm đây truyền control sinh
viên ngoạn
đương nhiên khi mình bấm vào control of
mà mình chưa truyền đã trường gì thì tôi
muốn hiển thị an toàn bộ lớp đúng ạ thì
mình sẽ làm nhà thì ở bên ở bên này vẫn
sẽ gọi
Ừ tôi sẽ ở đây tôi sẽ phải sửa một tí
trong sợ mày à tôi sẽ không gọi Hoàng
controller tổng nữa mà tôi sẽ gọi cho
lớp controller là sinh viên controller
được
Ở đây là tôi sẽ là ít MT
đôla get đ
xe
[âm nhạc]
container
kéo lúc đầu không có này thì tôi sẽ gọi
hoặc Angeles bình thường con Eo sao ạ
chợ hoa cài ở rộng như hôm trước tôi làm
thưởng này dùng xích cây đấy tôi thử
dùng những xích cay cho mấy ông quen nhé
thích cây đấy
nếu mà không trống này cho biết
controller Cho
xem điện Castle này à
anh ở đây controller
Nếu lúc đầu cây là chấm thì mình sẽ
White thằng controller gấp thế này
subject này còn đều cây ở lớp
Ừ
thì mình sẽ đi qua lớp controller thằng
nào
gì
Ừ tôi thường nhà ở Tôi thường là nếu mà
Real thì nó sẽ để tên nó trước cái chữ
container cơ
thì nó sẽ kiểu là nó sẽ viết hoa cơ chắc
là tôi cứ tạm viết kiểu nhà trong đêm
quen đã
không anh em không hứng thủ viết code để
ở đây cả
sinh viên này à
là như này và mình sẽ có một cái đẹp khô
gần như hôm trước mình có một cái đẹp
đâu thì sẽ cho ở đây rằng ạ cái là kiểu
đấy Ăn đậu Nó đôi khi nó gợi ý gửi cho
hai đúng không Không tin Không Không tìm
thấy controller phù hợp trở lại ạ
ừ ừ
hợp này báo lỗi không tìm thấy file này
nhà tôi bước ra xử nhập viện gia đình
ngay nó sẽ báo lại ngay đúng không Không
tìm thấy phù hợp còn mặc định lúc đầu
vào nó sẽ để làm menu nóng lạnh bởi một
controller nước này rồi Bây giờ mình sẽ
tạo nên lớp controller
Ê
mấy ông có thể là tạo hẳn một thư mục ăn
cho lợn được thường mà tôi cũng sẽ tạo
một phần của chung 1 của controller đấy
thôi Tấm và trong đấy cũng là một cách
hay ừ bây giờ có khi tôi tạo luôn mày
Ông nhé để tạo nhé sẽ là một thư mục là
cần cho lợn
tôi làm kiểu dạng là nhét hết vào trong
như này cho mấy ông quen dần đi tôi sẽ
tạ Nếu thế tôi nhét hàng ngày vào trong
ngày trước đã
tôi phải sửa lại các tên hay nữa tên là
rút đi
này
A và cắm trailer hay trèo lớp theo kiểu
nha à
anh kể tiện mà Mấy ông về sau Sửa tên nó
dễ hiểu nha Coffee vào cái xong OK đương
nhiên vẫn chưa có hoài vậy mình sẽ tạo
lớp cần trả lời nha ở bảng xếp
là lúc đầu chưa có gì cả Lúc nào chưa gì
cả như này thì mình sẽ cần là mình sẽ
kết nối đến thằng Mua đồ xong rồi từ
hàng mua đồ mình sẽ lấy toàn bộ lớp xong
rồi in ra ở trong một phòng vi là không
ạ Mình sẽ gọi mà mua đồ này
cái tên này ạ
ờ ờ
Ừ nhưng mà như như bây giờ các bạn thấy
thời bây giờ nó sẽ có hai mua đồ luôn
một mua đồ mua đồ lớp mua đồ mua đồ sinh
viên không ạ Mình có thể là tạo phần 1
thư mục nữa là thư mục
đi mua đồ mà mình sẽ có
I love đ.tp mấy ông thầy bắt đầu tôi tạo
rất nhiều thư mục con ở rất nhiều Phai
đúng không Mình có thể khó theo nên mày
ông vào vào của tôi xem hoặc cào vào
link của bạn lớp trưởng để mà xe mình nó
tiện hơn Xem của tôi là file nó bị lại
tải nhỏ mấy ông sẽ không tập trung không
không không theo dõi được không ạ
Anh thường à Bây giờ tôi còn tạo thành
một file riêng file con dê cơ tôi cấu
tạo một cái con nít trước đã nhé
à à
hình
ảnh chưa nhiều nhưng mà rõ ràng các bạn
khác loạn đấy ạ
gọi nó đề xuất hiện mãi nhé cao
Selection from Plus này
sau đó thì mark
từ
khi nói ở đây nó báo không tìm thấy bảng
vì tôi chưa reset lại cái này sẽ vào đây
reflect này thì nó sẽ tìm lại được các
bạn đó
à tiện đúng không
Đấy nó sẽ trả về kết quả vào trong cái
Ji Sub này sau đó thì thằng này mình sẽ
mình sẽ gọi đến zwei đến một thằng view
Sao chửi mày tôi view tôi lại chưa nhỏ
đó nữa lại thương một con nữa là lớp như
thế này sau đó tôi tạo một thư mục nữa
nó lại Index chạm p p
gì để mà Thì địa danh sách
I I love này duc.tp như thế này vào đây
Bây giờ mình mới hiển thị ra
danh sách lớp này mình cho một cái thấy
bồ
không sao
mã tên kiểu ngay sau đó thì mình sẽ có
ích này
em bị sốt từ kết quả này à
em
mã này nó chủ đề tên
đó in ra
Ừ cái cảnh báo để kệ đi bởi vì bản chất
cái virus này mình lấy từ Model cơ Chẳng
phải là không Hiệp trả lại này đó mình
sẽ có bộ đồ
a bít lại
nó như thế này
ừ ừ
qua với cô đi à Thằng chụp cho tao dùng
cái gì để được chuyển có sau đây tách
được à
Ừ ok
Bây giờ đưa nhiên cho cả lớp nào thì cho
ngoài như này bây giờ sử tôi có tạo
trước một lớp mình không xem nhé
anh ở đây rất là trình đi thôi Để hẳn
tiếng Việt có dấu với ạ
đời
khi họ sao nó không nhập với có dấu
anh về nha
đó lâu chưa
thêm này mình sẽ có Hz ở đây
trong trường hợp này trong trường hợp
này thì mệt
Ê mày ông sẽ thấy là thức a khi bấm Hz
này nếu mà Mấy ông truyền Á trên không
thôi giống như hôm trước là là crash
chẳnghạn đúng không Thế này bấm vào nhá
thiếu mấy ông thấy làm mất cái
controller thì mất mất cái controller
gốc mà ông nhận để em ạ đang controller
ở lớp đúng không thì bấm vào thì nó sẽ
ghi đè lên cái cái cũ để làm mất đi ông
ạ nhiều ra cách kiểu như là nó không tốt
Nó không tốt thì đang nghe mày ông sẽ
phải truyền cả controller l vào trong
máy nữa thế này
những
ngày này bằng lớp như này
đây như thế này nhưng mà
nói chung là tí rồi sẽ chỉ mấy ông sửa
mà cái đoạn này nhanh cho cho dễ Hiệp à
ừ ừ
Ông
Hà ông ý ông có thể truyền kiểu em ở đây
đúng không ạ thử nhà à
bấm lại bấm này đâu Ông bảo em kiểu gì
không không không kiểu như thấy được bản
chất khi bấm vào đường link mà Kiểu gì
nó suy nghĩ đèn lên nó sẽ không kiểu như
thế được trừ khi ở mấy ông chơi trò là
mấy ông điện than thở không không cách
nào cái đấy Được mà Chắc là ông sẽ phải
ghi lại thôi nghe cách tôi thường ai làm
không Đây đây là cách tôi thường làm nhé
ngờ tôi có một ví dụ như mấy ông cậu
ngay tại mấy ông cứ bây giờ có bấm là ok
ngay đúng không Bây giờ mình sẽ
ở tạm Tắt bớt nó ngoài đã thôi Dùng dào
Buddy thì trong trường hợp này thì lại
bắt chước giống như lần trước và lần này
mình sẽ lấy á truyền ra đúng không ạ thì
thường à Kiểu gì Bị sẽ lấy áo trần nhận
thường tôi sẽ lấy ác Trần ngay từ trong
khai báo ở bên này tội lẽ trên đời này
để đỡ đoạn mấy cái thằng container kia
phải lá ison sẽ thay bảo trước ở trên
đây là cách ngắn gọn hơn viết của thằng
này theo pp 7 nó còn ngắn hơn tôi sẽ
viết lại cái này theo cách của P7 nha
mình em sẽ thấy Container bằng
đồ ghét controller này
hỏi chấm hỏi chấm như thế này
anh Bày cách viết của pp7 đội lên thì nó
sẽ biết được cả ngày nghĩa là kiểm tra
hàng ngày tồn tại không không sẽ lấy
xanh này Đấy 1 trong 2 hai tay sai của
tôi đang mặc định đến của tôi là 5.6
không có nghe mấy ông đổi VTV7 của tôi
7.4 em ạ nó thì nó sẽ không báo lỗi nữa
Ok chưa đó như này nó sẽ tiện hơn nếu
bạn Ok thì
tôi sẽ lấy a trên về đúng như thế
này thỉnh thoảng tôi sẽ tối ưu cốt cho
mấy ông xem một tí không ạ Không hẳn cái
tắt làm đâu tối ưu lại cách viết cho
nhìn cho thoáng hơn nhưng mà không phải
hiểu nhé Nó không khác gì vậy bản chất
nó không khác gì nhau cả
Ừ Ừ
đang định nói rồi bạn ở
bên Angeles này thì bây giờ trong trường
hợp mình lại thích cái thôi trong trường
hợp là á chân Ê
bà cách là trống như thế này thì mình sẽ
White toàn bộ đoạn này
a subject ông ạ Còn nếu trường hợp cây
là les thì mình sẽ chỉ đi qua một cái
view một cái lớp và đầy C class 6A
Ừ nếu không sẽ thấy cái này copy pate
khá nhiều đấy
a form này
ở đây là tên đến phút 22
à à
khi tách mềm tên Tân thêm mặt nạ
khi
ờ
ờ hỏi chấm
bài hát chân bằng
store and controllers
bằng lớp
kẹo nhà à
chú chó Mày không thấy nó sẽ nhảy sang
cái này không ạ Và khi mình Điền ở đây
là sự là bảo mật rồi lại rất bảo mật
thêm một lớp mới không ạ thêm vào không
báo lỗi gì cả và bản chất là nó sẽ nhảy
vào cái cây này một cái phố ở đây nè
anh không ạ Thật sự đây đã bình thường
nên phải có một cái đẹp vô để trong
trường hợp người dùng nhập quá trình
tinh nhật hát Trần của lớp sai rồi em ạ
Các bạn rồi ghi rõ lớp vì sao còn không
biết được nó nhảy và thằng lớp hai thằng
sinh viên nó sai à
chỉ có như này nhưng mà bây giờ ra sự
mình store và như này gọi thằng mô đồ và
nhôm trước mình bảo là mình sẽ lấy lại
cái thứ mà mình đã điền trong form ở bị
caro sẽ lấy tên bằng đôla hot
tên như này rồi chuyền vào thằng Model
modem trường hợp này thì mình lại copy
cái xích cây này
à à
à à anh không cần giấy FO
thì mình sẽ chị có chia trường hợp là
trường hợp
anh nói chung là kiểu gì nó cũng giờ mấy
trường hợp đúng rồi nó còn không mà
không ngậy và thằng mua đồ chúng nó sai
không cần đấy phô gì cả anh ở đây mình
sẽ là
em ra mà Insert into love tên
là tên
nhà đúng ạ
hoa nhà
chạy này không báo lỗi nhưng mà cứ quay
bên này em làm lại chắc ngoan ra bảo mật
rồi
Ừ thế giờ Xóa Xóa Thằng này đi này đó
thì dao động ngay nó ngoan ý cho mấy bạn
này thật ra bởi Hôm trước mình làm rồi
nhưng mà các bạn thấy nó phức tạp hơn
điểm mà nó trên nhỏ nhiều thêm một con
nữa thì mới ông sẽ bị loạn hơn tí nhưng
mà tội sẽ tôi Nhanh cái mấy loại này Hôm
trước làm rồi mà bạn đấy thì đôi khi có
nhiều Buổi tôi sẽ nhắc lại kiểu như thế
này nhưng tôi sẽ thay đổi một tí thì mới
ông phải nhận Nguyễn buổi hôm trước đã
buổi hôm nay nằm kiểu nó đỡ bị choáng
chứ tôi không muốn lại chỗ hoàn toàn
được không ạ còn lại hoàn toàn thì lưu
lại video của mình cho à
cái đít này em
controller
bằng lớp này em này
mã nữa
ừ ừ
Mã
ngày để xuất ra nhiều ạ
anh
sửa à
quen cái kiểu nhà đã để mà khi mà xăng
Facebook thì mấy ông thấy nhẹ nhàng vãi
không mua đổ em không hướng về bên chưa
Cho làm ok đâu nên là mua đồ của em nó
vẫn đang hơi nông dân một tí khi mà em
để sang ov10 C và các hợp âm nữa thì thì
nó mới khác còn bây giờ mua đồ kiểu ngay
thì bạn chất nó giống cái á p thuần
Chẳng qua bây giờ nó suốt cây si cây
thôi nó sẽ là thích cây thôi bà bây giờ
mình đang làm thì cả mới xe rồi chia nhỏ
những cái hại ra dư âm từng từng mảng
từng mảng riêng đến các bạn hiểu rồi
chưa chưa có USB thì đây cả controller
hay mua đồ bây giờ nó vẫn đang rất là
nông dân
à à
ờ ờ đó bé mình bấm vào sửa này thì đương
nhiên là lại phải khai báo ác chân ở bên
bên cần trả lời trước đúng không
Ừ ừ thì hôm nay thầy dự giờ tôi biết mà
thấy cảnh báo trước rồi
Không sao Không sao ạ ừ ừ
view nữa để mà hiển thị ra Adidas nóng
hoặc format
trong trường hợp này thì đây sẽ là edit
này
thì mình sẽ lách mình copy đoạn này thôi
đó là celexa for love em mình sẽ
ba que
a mã bằng đô la mã này mà lần này mình
chỉ trả về một thằng thì lại về dụng
phases ai đúng không như này trở về đâu
Like xong rồi chuyền vào trong tháng ADN
này thằng ấy đi này bản chất là như tôi
bảo thì hãy copy đã ký kết của thằng
Grant này nó sẽ dai đít này
lưu cho nó
mày không thấy gợi ý gì đâu xin mãi một
tí phút hai lần đi
chị thay bằng đỏ như thế này
vẫn công nhận bây giờ nó không Tôi thấy
cách gõ nó không tối ưu được bảng bên
sau khi tách nên nó đề xuất thế giới
Ngon hơn thôi
ở đây mã này
để sửa đấy
tôi gõ hơi bị nhanh quá với ông không
biết nếu không theo kiểu không ạ
ở đó như thế này
bây giờ lập trình như này sợ đi
đi đái Tuấn sửa sửa Bây giờ mình lại lại
Cập nhật lại bên lại vẫn điệp khúc mà
cần cho lo xong rồi vợ là mua đồ đúng 0h
đêm này
lấy về
Anh tên này
Ừ ừ ừ rồi Tao quên điều hướng đấy phải
thêm xong rồi tôi phải điều hướng về tôi
quên đấy ạ bây giờ sợ lại
đúng không không không Em muốn làm kiểu
các bạn chưa động và phong trần vội xanh
Ok thì em sẽ làm theo cẩu vừa phong
phanh trần luôn
em có mấy giờ tôi Em đang làm hay cỡ là
em hiểu gì anh nghĩa là một file Mua đồ
xong rồi tạo theo nhiều phương trinh
không ạ Cũng cũng cũng giống giống làm
xanh OB thì mình cũng gọi đến Hàm Phong
trên mấy thước của nó thôi
ờ ờ
ạ bây giờ bản chất thì mình vẫn là xích
cay xong rồi mình sẽ chia trường hợp ra
được mà gọi đến gọi đến cái tương ứng
của nó nên nó không khác gì nhau mấy
à à
thể loại mà
sang update này mình sẽ update
a date of này set
tên bằng tên này hay ở thỉnh thoảng nó
cực và ở sông được trồng dễ nhìn
đưa tên này à
ở trong cái tôi thấy trợ chung thích dễ
nhìn hơn đấy ạ
Ừ ok xe tên bằng tên chỉ còn chạy thôi
không cần trả kết quả này không ạ à
khi
chạy thử đã nhá không báo lỗi này đó ra
được rồi này khi mà chắc chắn Các bạn
thấy đều ổn như này thì các bạn sẽ điều
hướng quay về không ạ
hết đồ
cái sân này
khi chuyển sang mua đồ làm việc với tao
bây Đúng rồi mua đồ làm việc với
database Nhưng mà như bạn chất thì mình
vẫn phải
đã theo theo ý Có phải bạn đang thắc mắc
kể ý của anh Chánh đang góp ý các bạn
kia có bí là mình có thể không cần dùng
thích cày đây này mình sẽ tạo những
phông chữ nhỏ phăng chuyện nhỏ để mà sau
đó thì mình sẽ gọi em thằng thằng mình
sẽ gắn inplus hả Mua đồ gọi phanh chân
của thằng này sợ là Shake to này để lấy
tất cả này nè select One để lấy một
thằng hèn gì đó
à à
anh em thì đang không muốn độngphong
trường vội em muốn chị làm sui cây thân
hết Còn khi mà sang o p lại động và
phanh chân mới thất các thứ thứ sao
đã bình tĩnh
đoạn này thì bản chất là lỗi cái chân nó
vẫn sẽ à
về bản chất nấu cái sân ở đây cái đoạn
Index nó vẫn sẽ nhảy về nách không ạ
nhưng mà nó sẽ hỏi chấm thêm khá dài
dòng này tôi thường sẽ hỏi chẳng hạn các
bạn lại khá dày được gì
a&p đúng không
Không cần ăn kiêng gì cả chỉ có Zalo
thôi bằng lớp này chắc lại thử nhé á
à à
là khuyên nhau
làm thêm phải xóa nữa xa lạ này
à à
đã
một cái gì cả Chỉ đơn giản là Delete để
xóa thôi thì cái lại xa ngắn sẽ Delete
này rồi Đây là mấy thoát ra ghét này
anh tặng tắt cái đĩa ai đúng không ở đây
mình sẽ có cái Delete này à Ừ mình ạ
I Delete for love
ngài xong đĩa xong rồi
anh ấy nhỉ
đã xóa này
cho điều hướng quay trở lại
Ừ ok chưa để em làm đầy đủ tính năng
thêm sữa xóa nhanh của lớp mấy ông sẽ
thấy là vừa rồi thực cả không ăn nhanh
lắm nếu là tôi thì copy cái này sang bên
copy toàn bộ Cái này sang bên sinh viên
nhưng mà ông sẽ thấy có thể nhanh nha
nhìn cậu cách tôi copy nhá Ờ
Để tôi tạm tắt hay đi đầu tiên mọi thứ
vẫn tự nhiên tôi đã khai báo đây một cái
là sinh viên rồi ông ạ Tôi sẽ copy đầu
tiên copy lớp này rồi copy sinh viên này
nhớ đây trong trường hợp mà Mấy ông làm
theo kiểu là
nó sẽ có khác nhau một tí của vì sinh
viên đây còn thêm một cột cột bạn lớp
nữa như cột mã còn có tên là giống nhau
em cách copy nó cũng khá nhanh thôi Đây
Anh thường là tôi chỉ đổi toàn bộ truyện
lớp ở trong này tôi để hết hàng triệu
sinh viên làm được nếu mà Mấy ông làm
theo cậu quy tắc là cậu đặt tên file tên
biển có xử nó hợp lý nó giống nhau để
thử cho mình xem nhé à
khích đâu
nhưng có một nhược điểm đây tôi không
thích cái vụ là cái controller này ăn
cho lợn này nó đôi khi nó lặp lại được
đúng thì biến controller ở ở đây mình
thấy báo ấy thế là tôi thường là tôi sẽ
I read luôn được mình controller vào
trong may bay để tôi ví dụ mày Ông ấy
ông dễ hình dung hơn
này tạm bỏ tạm bỏ đầy giá nhé
ở đầu tiên mình có vào bên A
cho sinh viên trước
Anh chưa tìm hiểu về mua đồ sinh viên
đúng không Ok tôi sẽ khai báo một cái
mua đồ sinh viên ở đây à
có một file khác nữa thì ổn hơn này ở
thì tôi sẽ tầm cái thoại cái này sao một
cái file
cài đặt tên file wi-fi Connect p
chậm nhai
mấy ông sẽ chỉ cần Wifi này là ổn
mấy ông thấy là rõ ràng là cái file lớp
này nó cùng cấp về cái file con ếch
không ạ Nếu không sẽ nghĩ ra là chị gọi
con ếch nghe được đâu em ạ Nhưng không
Cái cái cách của mình bây giờ mình đi
quay một cái thứ gì đói mình sẽ phải
luôn
cho mình mình sẽ phải luôn nhìn từ cái
file Index bởi vì bản chất mình luôn
đứng ở file đắt nên là nó sẽ phải ghi rõ
là nhà mua đồ cho cái chéo con ếch cái
này cơ mà ông sẽ thấy là từ controller
mình đã phải làm như thế rồi rõ ràng
trong container nhá mày không để ý kỹ
lại nha trong Trailer này đáng lẽ thường
với ông nghĩ là mình sẽ phải thoát ra
khỏi có chút một con trả lời xong rồi
vào thư mục Mua đồ xong mới gọi gọi được
và những cái này hay vào máy cày view
đúng không ạ nhưng mà không thấy rõ ra ở
tôi chỉ gọi tên thư mục ngay thôi Bởi vì
bản chất là mình vẫn đang đứng từ trên
đấy để mà gọi xa những thằng kia đúng ạ
nên thằng này làm thế chúng ta sẽ về đi
quay ở ngay
bạn tiếp theo bể nát chân là xong rồi
đây tôi hiện đội hết đồng loạt
và đáp án sinh viên là xong đấy à
và đương nhiên là cái này vẫn chưa chạy
được hết đâu vì có thêm một cột nữa ở
cột mã lớp nữa cứ bình tĩnh đã
view này
đương nhiên à Cái này tôi chỉ đang chỉ
cho bé ông về cái mẹo vặt để mà có thể
làm được nhanh thôi Bình thường à chúng
ta biết được là mỗi bảng mình phải làm
nhiều cái khác nhau ấy không hẳn là copy
được Kiểu hoàn toàn như này đâu Như Ý
tôi là khi mà các bạn làm một cái mô
hình mvc rồi làm cậu nhóc các thứ ổn rồi
các bạn thay đổi sửa nó vẫn dễ và có thể
gọi là sao chép cũng dễ với tính năng về
các bạn nữa tính nào chị xem thêm sửa
xóa ngày copy rất là nhanh rất dễ các
bạn chỉ cần đổi tên bảng đã xong nãy giờ
tôi thật là tôi cố tình để hẳn Nó là
kiểu Huy hàm phát cốt ở Nga ghi hình
trên mạng ngay thực tế là nếu có thể mất
cái ví dụ ở mấy cũng thể đổi thay bồ như
ngày bằng sinh viên ở trên đấy này
sôi Ông mấy ông chị còn hay hết toàn bộ
xuống dưới là thấy bồ nhé mày anh thấy
hết toàn bộ xuống dừa như thế này thì
cũng không cần được ăn chôn hát Giống
Như Tôi vừa làm nó mấy ông chỉ cần đúng
đúng rồi mình không chỉ cần đổi tên bảng
thê bộ trên này thì toàn bộ Cái dưới nó
sẽ nhận nếu không hiểu thì không ạ Đấy
nó rất là nhanh rất tiện như thế khi mà
các bạn làm thì cậu mô hình tưởng như
này nghĩ ra các bạn hồi trước các bạn
làm trong đón một các bạn có rất nhiều
file mỗi file lại phải kết nối các thứ
thứ rất lằng nhằng thuốc ta với ngọn đấy
mời các bạn chỉ tập chung 1 file Đây là
các bạn thì cần sửa cái pha đấy tất cả
chỗ khác đều rồi chạy đúng
Ừ đấy quy tắc của mới xe nghĩa là các
bạn sửa ở chỗ liên quan cơ sở dữ liệu
được các bạn sửa một file thôi sửa Rose
để sửa một file thôi những chỗ khác nó
vẫn sẽ chạy à à
khi ở vẫn phải xem qua cách
cách
cái cấu trúc cách viết của TP như nào đã
ô chữ k nhảy sang cái này thì sẽ hơi
loạn một tí đấy trừ khi cấp
Trừ khi bạn có nên sẵn giống như nên sẵn
Java có thứ tình nhảy sáng mới sẽ ok thì
mẹ thì ông có nhận cũng dễ hiểu thôi
tôi sẽ bị đổ cái này thì tên biến
control thì nó sẽ ổn hơn à
nhiên là bây giờ thì đâu Cả em vẫn còn
Hiếu ví dụ thứ nhất là bây giờ tôi muốn
gì Tên lớp này
Ừ chắc ạ
Tôi muốn làm một cái là tên lớp nghe
chẳng hạn ạ
em ạ thì cái tên lớp này lại ở đâu
Anh tên lớp này mình sẽ gọi đến ở bên
modal sinh viên này mình sẽ
nữa
bộ phim sex thầy trò i i
ạ
Lớp chấm tên HP love nhà để lấy được đến
lớp ở đây lời chứ Thằng này nó tự động
Asiad cho mình
sẽ đầy đủ đi
3 - đánh e định xài hết toàn bộ biến cả
tên Mạnh thành nhà tiếng Anh ấy nhưng mà
bị Hôm nay tôi thấy cũng khá nặng rồi
tôi dậy cậu vẫn
vẫn tương đối thôi chưa dậy mấy ông Tiến
anh hoàn toàn
à để buổi sáng nữa nhé Nói chung là tối
cư mỗi buổi tôn thêm một tí thôi chứ
đùng một phát mà khác hẳn cái mấy ông
thoáng này
buổi sau xanh opal mày cũng thấy nó khác
nhiều đấy
Anh Thọ đây để không ra được nghỉ cho
lớp mã lớp Ừ đúng rồi nó không ra bởi vì
khi mình dùng cho như này à
cho mày xong cái đó sinh viên mình đã có
lớp nào đâu Thì nó sai mình phải rep cho
này đúng nét voi
nóng ạ bây giờ xử tôi cho lớp đang vào
lớp 2 cho mở lớp là hai này
đó Ok chưa
em còn nếu mà Mấy ông không mà dụng nét
cho là mày không sẽ bắt buộc sinh viên
nào sẽ có lớp nóng lạnh thì không cần
phải ghép choi nữa à
Ừ ok Bây giờ tôi giờ xử tốt thêm một
sinh viên mới Thêm bây giờ trong trường
hợp này không cần ấy không phải ở hiển
thị mũi tên nữa thêm môi trường hợp này
mình sẽ cần làm gì mình cần phải gọi đến
Hằng à
ạ Bây giờ Bây giờ nó sẽ sinh là cái vấn
đề này
giống như giống như anh Tráng Vừa nãy có
nói đó Bây giờ trong trường hợp là nếu
class này Grande Ariana Grande nhá
Angeles nhớ về tôi gọi mua đồ của lớp
Ừ để lấy ra toàn bộ lớp để hiển thị hiển
thị vào trong trong ngày để mà Shake
Shake option tất cả lớp thì cái hàng mua
đồ mà không sử dụng nữa không ạ
mã sản phẩm mua đồ này sẽ không sử dụng
nữa nhé Hiểu gì cho anh
khi mà ạ chị
Em hãy để tôi nói lại đi nhé
em tắt đợt mà cái này đi mày ông xem kỹ
nhé
này thả trên của thằng này đang là Kris
đúng không quá chừng bên này không có
thằng a hundred này và nó cũng sẽ hiểu
là thằng controller cũng không phải con
cho lợn lớp này là nó sẽ không gọi xong
cái này đâu
ừ ừ
Vì thế nên là giống như anh chạy mưa anh
nói là bạn Chất hàng ngày thứ thích cây
ở bên mua đồ nó không tối ưu đúng không
Mình sẽ đổi hết cái này thằng Phong chân
lại Bây giờ em mới bắt đầu Dạy Phần đấy
thì nếu mà trong trường hợp một bảng như
hôm trước thì mình làm được theo kiểu
dạng sức cây cảnh ngay Còn bây giờ thì
mình sẽ đổ cái toàn bộ phanh chân và
mình sẽ gọi nó theo phán trình đây mình
sẽ có những cái phân sinh kiểu nhà ở
cho tôi sẽ đặt tên ở đây trường đặt nó
là tên của căn cho l sau đó kết hợp với
tên của mấy thức sẽ hiểu lớp cả nhà sẽ
lách này à
không biết được chèn vào
biến này sợ ở biển này không tràn được
vào
ừ ừ
thì ông gọi cái phân Trần kiểu ngại thì
ông sẽ phải có Return rồi một cái sống
sẽ gọi lại nó
là như thế này nhá được thử ví dụ cho
mấy ông nhé Tôi tạm à
roble thay thay vì thay vì kẹo trong này
đợi em tí
a reward thằng Hải đúng không cho thì
mình sẽ reset bằng lốp xe Lead ngày để
gọi lên các phóng viên này
anh
còn thằng con ếch này thì mình sẽ đổi
Global
Anh em lâu không động Global cơ Để em tí
nhé ạ
đấy con lô bồ cả Loco rôcô đâu Nè đây à
ý nghĩa làm chỉ kia các bạn khai báo
biến ở ngoài phong trần các bạn dùng nó
bên trong thì chúng ta sẽ gọi của Global
cả ngay ok
ra con ếch này
thì mình sẽ sử dụng được biện con nít ở
trong này cho mình sẽ truyền biển vi rút
ra ngoài này khi đói suốt
ở đây mình sẽ đặt tên nó là lớp thêm chữ
s cũng được
ấm chỉ có nhiều lớp
ạ sau đó thì từ lớp này mình mới gọi
mình truyền vào trong thằng class này
tại Đợi mình tí
hoàng sa vai tách phố ích này nó thông
minh hơn
trong trường này tôi không thích dùng để
biến Vietsub nó cả x bởi vì tí nó sẽ bị
ngon ấy tôi sẽ phải đặt tên nó tên bia
nó hơi bị chiều kia tí đi
à à
à à Ờ Ờ
mình là
pê sô đa lớp tại mã này
Copy đoạn này đi
Anh
tên này à
bận đợi thì nhé
nó báo lỗi Tại sao rồi nhỉ aquila
sạch xà phòng lớp sau rồi nghỉ hai thằng
con ếch này có vấn đề rồi
anh ạ
ạ Bây giờ là ít công ty dùng mvc thuận
lắm gần như sẽ dùng
cho em toàn dùng câu lạc bộ cả nhà ạ
cách sửa nhà như thế nào bây giờ cái con
ếch nó không tìm được bây giờ thử con
ếch nữa nhé
đài được đi à
ở
đâu mày nghỉ à
you make me rồi đây có vẻ không được này
vì nó không nhận biết con lắc đấy
hai thằng 2 ngày khác nhau mà đúng không
rõ ràng tôi thấy y hai thằng khác nhau
thằng như này thằng rưỡi chết
cho tôi thử đổi nó thành Nobody
quen à
được cái vì con ếch này lại nhỉ
tôi thường cái này tự động rất lâu rồi
ờ ờ đợi tôi một tí còn không thì mình sẽ
phải chơi cách này chơi một cách ta hơi
nông dân một tí Mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ tạo cái này là một cái phong
chân và phương trên kinect Sau đó mình
sẽ có thành các phòng trên đấy cũng được
đây ạ
Ừ nó kìa bình tĩnh
con ếch này à
Lại Sau đó thì tôi sẽ ghi tên Hoàng con
nít này à
Ừ nó thì đây sẽ là con ếch
bằng hơi nông dân của Thị
Như lại ạ
ở đó thế này cũng được lại một cách
anh
alo đương nhiên à với sau ông sang model
không phải làm cái kiểu nông dân ở ngay
đi
trong này đúng rồi nhá ạ
dòng 44 lỗi
à à
có đồ rồi à
cho tôi Tôi chỉ đang nói qua việc là
giống như mày anh kia bạc đó là mình sẽ
tống hết cái nào tăng trưởng thì cách
cách làm nó sẽ tiện hơn địa là nó không
áp dụng được thích cái ở trong Model
giống như hôm trước mình làm nữa nếu
mình làm hiện nhiều và đúng ạ
Cái này nó hơi khó hiểu một tí nhưng mà
khi mà xanh Ok buổi sau tôi hướng dẫn bé
ông xã Ok thì cái đoạn này sẽ gọn hơn
gọn hơn khá nhiều đây tôi sẽ tạm Xóa
những cái đoạn này đi này nó sẽ viết lại
theo cậu đúng kiểu dạng ngay trong đó
không xem nhé à
anh gửi tin nhắn
gì này cái em đã in sơ về đúng
vợ Totti Story Of em sẽ mất trước kiểu
kia một cái lớp Index này
ở mặt đất này
I love stoned lưu lại ở đây đôla tên
truyền RT là đây này tiếp theo
khi edit đúng không
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ
thôi chỉ cần chuyển mã về thôi ở đây
mình sẽ Return đó là ít này à
tôi
lại edit một cái nào đó này
ừ ừ
v-app đê ê
em chuyển mã này chuyển tên này
à à
em không cần trả về cái gì này
à
mà delay cũng thể lớp Delete đợi tôi một
tí
à à
ở đó
mình sẽ biến thành các fan trình kẹo kéo
ngay nhá cách mình gọi nó để để tôi sang
bên A controller
lớp để làm lại trong mấy ông thì ông sẽ
thấy nó sẽ kiểu cách gọi nó sẽ như nào
đầu tiên nó báo lỗi mình sẽ sửa lại cái
biển controller lớp một tí
số bài gọi thằng lớp này chị sẽ có kết
quả trở về bằng xe lại bên lớp nhé mình
sẽ có lớp Index Gọi Love mien Bac ngay
để trả về cái thông tin kết quả nha à Là
được nó sẽ như nhau
a tiếp theo bên này crash
tên này đúng không gọi cho anh này sau
đó thì mình sẽ gọi đến cái Plus to này
chuyển đưa tên vào như thế này là sau
theo tôi thêm lại cho mấy ông Mày lập
trình
ăn thêm này
đó tôi thử xem lại nha
do đó nếu thêm đúng không
anh
em Em hiểu ý anh có thể sử dụng cái này
ở bên ngoài nữa đúng không
ở hướng bên ngoài ngay đúng không ạ sau
đó bên trong này sự xô bồ không
để em thử luôn nhé
anh em em chưa Rủ em chưa thử thử xem
nha Đây lớp
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ có lớp edit này
thì
mình sẽ có đôla x bằng lớp edit truyền
mã vào trong máy
đúng nhỉ
Ừ đúng rồi đúng không ạ
sữa này đó nó sẽ ra được đúng không em
thử đổi nó cả lớp đi này em đổ nha tấm
này ra ngoài đúng không ạ
ạ sau đây em sẽ lâu bồ
được nghỉ hơi dị
chợ hoa dại quá đấy ok
Ừ nếu thấy kiểu Đây cái này cho tiện hầm
tí thôi
anh như thế Mình có thể đóng nó kết nối
lại được sau hết toàn bộ mày cái thằng
này mình thể đóng cái nồi đấy
ở nhóm nhạc không không không không được
không được dọn hàng mua đồ này sớm mình
gọi mua đồ này Sao mình gọi cho này mình
không đóng được mình vẫn phải đau một
bên trong vẫn đóng ở bên trong cái phần
trên nó hợp lý hơn
khi đóng đóng này trở về đội ích này con
mẹ Ok rồi Tiếp theo vừa update cái này
sẽ update này
khi
anh hiểu update này à
ở đó ok rồi này tiếp theo lớp Delete thì
sẽ copy cái này đổi Delete này à
Em chỉ cần truyền mã này à
mấy ông thấy cái vừa rồi nó hơi bị loạn
một tí đúng bởi vì tôi bắt chước cái hôm
trước để làm cái 10 xe Opa mbcc od01 bạc
Ừ thì nó không cần nó chỉ cần suy cây
đơn giản là cả thằng bến container ở
phòng mua đồ thôi nhưng hôm nay bởi vì
nếu không thấy đã sang bên sinh viên thì
nó có thể gọi lại cái đùa lại cái thằng
ở bên lớp thế nào chắc chắn tôi phải tạo
hàm cả ngày để mà gọi đến Hàm đấy nó mới
được chứ nếu mà xích cây Thôi cậu trên
thì nó sẽ không được đấy tôi phải làm
hơi bị loạn ở một tí
Ừ nhưng mà ông thầy hôm nay có thể hơi
khó hiểu một tí nhưng mà đến A để buổi
sau khi mà xanh Ok hoàn toàn đấy thì mấy
ông nội thấy toàn bộ Cái này không phải
xích cây rồi em sẽ không phải suy cây
cảnh này nó sẽ dễ hơn dễ hơn đoạn này
nhiều rồi Hôm nay công nhận tôi khẳng
định hôm nay hơi loạn một tí
nhờ tí tôi đầy cốt lên mấy ông xe này
mình cũng sẽ thấy không cũng không Không
phải lỗi thế đâu
AE aber Nói chung là tôi xong tôi làm
lại được bên Cần bên lớp đúng không Tôi
sẽ đổi lại sang bên sinh viên mà không
xem nhé lỗi hết vậy chưa
Xóa hết đi anh ta lại sang bên sinh viên
nhé Mà tôi copy lại sang bên từ lớp 6
đến sinh viên mấy ông sẽ được đấy
Ừ thì tôi lại xóa đi
Ừ tôi sẽ làm lại
A Plus Anh Sinh viên vào xem nhé
cô gái lại copy đấy à
cô sinh viên à à
dám làm cái gì đó dễ mà Anh chắc chắn nó
phải hơi loạn làm gì đấy ta phải chấp
nhận điều đấy ạ
Ừ tôi sẽ copy hết này
dàng gì đâu mà chẳng hiểu tôi đang làm
gì đó copy đúng như cốt của thầy bảo
U16 vẫn chạy Magic Ok
ta lại này
là con view nữa
Em hãy sinh viên
từng cái một nhá Ừ anh sinh viên hoa
đội lớp hình sinh viên này ạ
ở
đầu tiên là mình cầm chỉ tên lớp và như
vừa nãy tôi bảo đúng không cái lớp này à
à à
Dạ vâng Em có xem quả cốt ở anh trên
công ty đúng không chẳng ai hiểu
à tên lớp này
thằng bộ đồ sinh viên này giống như vừa
nãy tôi bảo thì mình sẽ lap doi đi sẽ
lắp đẹp do đơn giản đi nhưng đây sẽ có
lẽ trôi ư
điều kiện vận sinh viên chấm này và alo
chấm tên stof đó
đây đây đôi khi các bạn Hiển thị Cái lỗi
này lỗi này thì các bạn cứ cố tra cái
dòng 17A ở đây rồi Các bạn không hiểu
tại sao nó lại sai cái phối này bản chất
là cái resort này nó không phải là cái
mạng không
forsberg nó không đúng nữa đây là nó
không phù hợp cho thằng phối tức là xa
nó vi rút này đang có vấn đề tất cả cái
câu truy vấn các bạn đang say thì thôi
tên lớp từng lớp về không Dạ
các bạn lớp là hai tên nó phải ra nhỉ
à À đúng rồi đúng rồi đấy vợ nó gợi ý
sau đây phải mà lớp Đúng
đó Ok tôi thêm một sinh viên mới này thì
lúc thêm này tôi cần hiển thị toàn bộ
danh sách lớp để mà thêm nó không ạ thì
bây giờ tôi sẽ sửa bên này
Ê thik White Cái thằng lớp này sau đó
thì tôi để lớp Index này
lại xong rồi Tôi đặt tên đây lớp hình
chữ S cho hiệu là lớp số di động từ mày
không nên chưa cho ai đâu nhé nên để
tiếng Anh ở hợp lý hơn đấy thì ở đây tôi
sẽ có lớp
select options
Ừ
dùng cái cậu không dùng không dùng kiểu
ngọc nhọn để không thể dùng cái này
ốp trần
à à
a cho tôi sẽ làm cho phím tắt nhanh để
mà Metro với lại nhanh nhìn lại khó chịu
quá à
à à
đó đang có một lớp thôi Nếu sẽ ra như
này ông ngoại ô
Ừ
nếu thấy là cách viết của tôi nó sẽ hiểu
xem xem xem làm gì nhé cái viết của tôi
bên hàng mua đồ này á Không không phải
bên bên hàng controller này không thấy
là rõ ràng mình kế thừa là được những
cái hàm những cái hàm mình đã viết ở bên
controller lớp bên lớp rồi đây cái Hàn
lớp indec đúng không Mình lấy lại được
cái cũ cái cách cách tối ưu của cốt hồi
hồi mà các bạn làm đón một thì các bạn
không tối được không sử dụng được cái cũ
các bạn viết lại cái Cậu axwell viết lại
có truy vấn các hư thứ và về sau giờ sự
về sau mình thay đổi tên bảng ở trên cầu
gì đó các bạn phải sửa rất nhiều file
đúng không Mình không mờ nên làm thế
mình lên về sau tôi sẽ hướng dẫn và mấy
ông mấy ông sẽ phải băn khoăn luôn băn
khoăn những cái điều này đó là khi mà về
sau mà thay đổi tên bảng 2 tên cột thì
mới ông Hạn chế sử ấy nó có thể thì làm
cách nào để mà hạn chế sửa khi đó ngoại
tên bảng tên một thứ gì đó Cái bản rồi
Ra ít khi mà đổi nhưng mà cũng có thể
lấy ví dụ thêm cột mới các từ thứ thì
mới ông sửa như thế nào để cho ít nhất
có thể Cái đấy bé là mục tiêu của cái mô
hình nó ra đời mô hình càng chuyên
nghiệp càng nâng cao thì nó sẽ cậu sẽ
cần tối ưu các bạn đỡ phải sửa cốt khi
mà có thay đổi mỗi gì đó
A và lẫn cả các bạn copy paste kiểu
ngang cũng nhanh nếu mà các bạn chỉ làm
tình năng giống nhau thì copy pate nó
dẫn ngay nó chỉ ở thay đổi một tên bản
trên cầu thôi khi sang khi sang razzil
thì tôi sẽ hướng dẫn mày ông đòi đánh
ngắn cực mỗi thằng mỗi khoanh chân có
hai dòng nữa Song Hành
mình không biết dùng tôi cái gì cả thông
cảm hơi kén không biết dùng rồi đấy à
ạ Bây giờ mình cấp mình sửa mình sửa bây
giờ mình sẽ có cả chèn thêm cả Đợi tí ở
đây Tôi phải chuyển thêm nêm và nó làm à
lớp nữa
mình chuyển đấy mà lớp này thì khi mình
to Mình lưu lại mình sẽ truyền lại mã
lớp ở trong này
Đây là bạn lớp và đương nhiên đây mình
chuyển thêm một cái biến là bạn lớp này
à à
Em
buồng ạ
cho hai thằng cùng một lớp
có
thêm
không lên nữa không Không nên tại không
lên Tại sao không đây xem nhé Insert mã
lớp trong bài đúng rồi nhỉ store này gọi
đến mà lớp mà lớp
tải lại cái này đã ok ok
mới phát nữa này
ừ ừ
control of sai đúng không ạ
Đấy nếu mà ông không để mình cái đoạn
này Thế nên vừa nãy tôi đang định bảo là
tôi có thể chơi cậu cách này tôi sẽ chơi
cái kiểu vãi chưởng ngay
em không đi ấy Nó nó cái cái xin nó vừa
rồi ở nhảy trên controller lớp nên hay
là nó không không lên được Wow phát nợ
này à
Ừ tao về câu trả lời sinh viên này đó đồ
rồi
Khi mà chắc chắn được rồi thì mình có
thể điều hướng quay về đúng không sẽ
điều hướng quay về
à à
anh Hải Tặc
mấy ngày Delete Delete thì nhanh họ
Delete thì thà chẳng giống vào nào Ngoại
bên mình sửa nữa
đã sửa thì mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ lại phải truyền lãi Cái
thằng à lớp Index ở bên sửa
á nhon nó lợi ích
cho tôi sẽ copy cái bên này đi
vào bên lớp edit
này mà tôi sẽ
anh đi xe đây
pp ở đây này ít
đồ lớp tại Mã anh bằng bằng bằng R = R
vật chất mà lớp
à à
em sợ gì nhiều gì ở site
có con ếch con ếch
I had it
này lỗi rồi
không bị lỗi
chứ nhỉ
chồng mình sẽ không khai bảo logo sẽ
không lỗi
em
bị lỗi biến kinect lòng ba à Nó đi quay
lại hay Thái cùng đi có ai à
A gọi tôi sẽ đổi hay Wendy
hai công ty vợ sao ạ
ok
02 tháng củ rồi có ai thằng con ếch nên
này ra thoại khai báo 2 phát
xong trận này sau đó hai phát
hoặc là mình có thể kiểm tra ngay trong
fashion là và phân sinh này tồn tại hay
chưa Nếu mà nếu có tồn tại rồi không cần
phải khai báo Lại Văn Sâm nữa cũng được
ở thời loạn không sao xanh Ok mẹ dạy
ngon cá MC là lại bắt đầu thời đoạn đấy
Ờ ok ở đây sẽ có lợi bu bu
à à
tử vi vu nằm Download Woa bị vụ
s7s lỗi bởi vì à mình mình phải ở trong
thì mình phải là biển trỗi mà mình phải
Escape cái cái dấu nháy nó mới không
biết anh Trỗi p phét ở lỗi này à
nghỉ mà tại sao nhẹ nhàng controller lớp
này tôi sẽ sai Ừ ừ
bên đợi tỷ lệ gì đây này phải sinh viên
đúng không ạ
trà sữa này
do đó nếu mà vừa rồi không sửa được tên
lớp đâu vì vừa rồi là mình chuyển mã lớp
xanh này sinh viên khi mẹ edit mình lấy
mỗi ạ
AE AE update thiếu mình sẽ phải lấy làm
à lớp xanh nữa mà lớp này
nếu sẽ thấy có nhược điểm đây là có bao
nhiêu cột tôi là khẳng khai báo bấy
nhiêu ở đây nó rất là dài dòng nóng bọn
mày không thấy không có bao nhiêu bao
nhiêu thương rồi khai bởi nhiều đây
những tâm đến xanh rosler mày cũng sẽ
không phải làm cái tình trạng này nữa sẽ
làm mấy ông tối ưu rất nhiều cái đoạn
này là nó sẽ không bắt ông phải ghi lại
câu SQL này mấy ông truyền bao nhiêu và
nó sẽ cập nhật bấy nhiêu cho mấy ông ở
chỗ nào sang bên đấy thôi mình thấy cho
sức mạnh của Uyên Quốc nó như thế nào
vẫn làm kiểu rất là nông dân hiểu Có bao
nhiêu phải điền đầy nhiều hơi khó chịu
gì chị đã có sửa đổi tên đổi lớp này nó
rồi đó đấy đầy đủ tính năng thêm sữa xóa
bột dài vãi chưởng Nếu bây giờ tình ra
khá là dài đấy nhưng mà tính ra là
nó sẽ nhỏ gọn theo kiểu là mấy ông bây
giờ thêm những cái bảng mới nữa thì mới
ông chỉ cần copy những copy cả thư mục
cả những cái file con này thôi
Rồi mấy ông chỉ cần giống như tôi bảo
cân cho Thái đổi để một cách để một cách
thôi nha mấy ông có thể tổng nghệ tổng
cái tên bảng này ra ngoài sợ mấy ông sẽ
chỉnh sửa tên bạn rồi còn gì thay đổi cả
Đấy là một cách
A và nhưng mà Mấy ông không cho mẹ nghĩ
việc tối với làm đâu về xanh cái đồ ăn
là xanh buổi sau tôi sẽ đập hết toàn bộ
về bạn ơi đi mấy ông có thể hôm nay thuế
hơi khó điểm đi hôm nay khó hiểu thật
khỏe hơi nữa thì hôm sau rồi cũng sẽ đập
đi để tôi lại là đại hội của mở Oppa cho
mấy ông
nghe mấy ông học hôm nay chị biết qua về
thứ nhất là khi m với xe
a sails 2 bảng thì nó sẽ khá lằng nhằng
hơn ở điểm mà nó sẽ phải tách riêng ra
gọi thằng Model của thằng khác rồi gọi
nhún Hàn đã như thế này đúng không ạ Nếu
không phải nhớ điều này đây một điều đầu
tiên cần nhớ lắm Nếu mày nhớ điều này đó
là gọi thằng mua đồ thằng khác và gọi
đến Hàm cả các đồ hoạ để mà buổi ông sau
tôi sẽ làm như khẩu hướng đối tượng là
sẽ cũng gọi mua đồ khác cũng gọi đến Hàm
cả các đúng như thế này như hôm nay luôn
nhưng theo dạng nào tiểu đối tượng thì
nó sẽ như nào thì nó sẽ theo kiểu đối
tượng rồi
anh nói trong buổi ông sao sẽ quan trọng
hơn bữa mày nên bộ của mày mấy ông thấy
là tôi dậy nó hơi bị ạ lại phải dùng tốt
nhất gừng cũng đúng vì tôi không hẳn ở
chuyên cái này từ lâu lắm rồi Không động
vào cái này nói thật là như thế bởi vì
đi làm thì chắc chắn tôi không động cái
này nữa đi làm đi Ở nhà lắm không ai làm
nên Cổ Phần Nông dân kiểu này cả nên mấy
ông thấy có thể ngoài Tại sao anh ấy kêu
mấy năm kinh nghiệm ở làm cái đoạn này
trông chán đấy Cá thứ bởi vì đi làm một
Tôi không động vào cái này nên lên là
tôi đang dạy cho mấy ông chỉ ở mức tương
đối để không biết qua biết qua nhé nó
cũng không cần phải hiểu sâu cái này bởi
vì hôm sau Rửa thì cũng
anh cũng đập đi xây lại và sẽ làm theo
kiểu tối ưu và nó chuyên nghiệp hơn cái
này nó vẫn là nông dân nên là
bởi lâu tôi không đọc Tôi nói thật như
thế có nghỉ đi dạy hơn một năm nữa đoạn
này có lâu lắm rồi có động vào đâu ạ
Ừ tôi còn không lên à Tôi có bị một tính
hơi bị sống Tí đó tôi sẽ không lên giáo
án được à
Ừ nhưng mà đến cái đoạn lelio thôi có
giá đầy đủ rồi và tôi đang làm nữa mẹ sẽ
sáng đoạn nào điều từ tôi tự tin hơn còn
hôm nay thì tôi hơi tệ Tí xin lỗi các
bạn
à à
từ hôm nay chị để cho biết thôi Mày chỉ
biết qua về MC làm hai bạn như nào còn
là buổi sau thì mình sẽ mới xe ốp thì
lúc đầy nó mới ổn không Tí và
khi tôi tôi nghĩa tôi sẽ dạy mới xe OB
cũng lại một bảng trước đi Tôi sẽ xóa
cho toàn bộ cốt này tôi là một bản trước
thì cho mấy ông đỡ bị choáng sợ buổi sau
nữa tôi sẽ làm cho hai bạn thôi buổi sau
nữa tôi có thể cân nhắc xem à lại tiếp
tục ôn lại hay là nhẹ xanh là gram đều
ngã
khi mà nhớ xanh yaourt thì chắc à Mà ông
sẽ thấy nó nó làm cái gì đó khác biệt
cốt nhàn hơn rất nhiều người tạo nhiều
pha ngày nữa tạm một file 1 Hifi thôi à
Anh
Huy cho ca là tôi dậy cho bé ông tôi
không chuẩn bị trước thì cũng làm tôi
nghĩ ở thực ra nó có một tí hay có một
tí Dở Những cái dở thì mới ông sẽ thấy à
đấy tốt cho bảo rồi có nghề ông ấy sẽ cả
báo sẽ nghĩ là thầy này đểu không học
nữa họ bị nản họ nghĩa khó quá không nữa
Nhưng nếu mà mày ông Nghĩa hướng
tích cực một tí giống như ông keo vào
bảo để học cách của một người
có một người có ký hiệu Nội đi Bắc giải
quyết vấn đề khi mà gặp một cái bớt thì
sẽ giải quyết như thế nào bởi vì thực tế
là các bạn đi làm các bạn sẽ có lúc gặp
bất Thôi thì là chuyển nghiệp ấy không
kiên nghiệp chữ nghiệp thì không nói chữ
nghiệp thì sẽ không ngờ gặp vớ vẩn ngoại
các bạn sẽ gặp những cái vấn đề gì đó
thì cách giải quyết
tư vấn đề các bạn như thế nào các bạn
tốn hàng giờ thì các bạn cầu nguyện nó
chạy đúng không các bạn sẽ giải quyết
cái cái đầy Nói như nào
3 bài tập bài tập thì tôi nghĩ là chưa
bài tập gì cả đâu Tôi nghĩ là mấy buổi
này nếu không chỉ cần xem lại này để
hiểu Đã mày cũng làm lại Nó là một cái
bài tập rồi còn à Buổi
Chắc là khi mà xanh.rar thôi sẽ bắt đầu
bắt mấy ông làm xem thêm sửa xóa một cái
gì đó rồi dần dần Sang Woo cũng bắt đầu
cũng chuẩn bị nhảy sang đồ ăn Đấy mẹ nó
cũng sẵn sàng đi xăm xắp lại thêm một
cái đồ nữa đấy đồ ăn hai mấy ông nghĩ đề
tài trước đi à Ừ đúng rồi anh kiểu gì
kiểu gì chẳng có bất
trên công ty em tệ hơn nhiều nước luôn
mỗi ngày làm xong một tính năng mỗi ngày
tao cho con bậc II
Ừ cái buổi hôm nay được à Không hẳn là
suôn sẻ lắm chỉ ra vẫn vẫn ra được kết
quả gì đó Nếu mấy ông xem thì ông xe mà
đó để thì được thì
ở đây tôi sẽ đẩy lên link ít nhé sẽ làm
ở với xe
i-sound hai bạn ạ
sự nghiệp
tôi nghĩa mày ông choáng trở không cần
phải học thêm gì nữa
em xấu nhỉ chúng ta tặng kết thúc đấy
thôi bạn Chào mấy ông nha
à à